[Musique]
alors que le journaliste et présentateur
jean jacques bourdin est accusé de
tentative d'agression sexuelle par une
ancienne collègue de bfm télé jean
jacques bourdin qui est visé par une
enquête de la justice après une plainte
pour harcèlement sexuel hier soir il
lancé sa nouvelle émission politique la
france dans les yeux un format américain
qui vise à confronter des politiciens à
panel d'une cinquantaine de citoyens la
première de la france dans les yeux
valérie pécresse devra répondre aux
questions des françaises et des français
dans son premier numéro l'animateur
recevait la candidate les républicains à
la présidentielle valérie pécresse la
france dans les yeux avec les français
les françaises et les français qui sont
autour de vous en pleine polémique elle
a tenu à s'exprimer en début d'émission
sur les faits dont jean jacques bourdin
fait l'objet un moment que certains ont
jugé malesan et auquel jean jacques
bourdin a très brièvement répondu alors
coulisser info réaction ce soir nous
vous faisons toutes les révélations sur
les dessous de cette séquence
et bien alors on va voir là on va voir
l'extrait suite on a une partie de
l'extrême moi je le veux le voir en
entier parce que pour moi c'est un grand
moment de télévision samantha va rester
ça bfm ils vont le vendre ses parts
valérie pécresse pour moi a lancé sa
campagne ça y est c'est parti un alors
un nid mission n'a pas été trop regarder
puisqu'elle a fait que six cent mille
téléspectateurs
c'est correct c'est pas fou hein on va
pas se mentir c'est pas la folie voilà
on s'attendait un petit peu plus moi je
vous dire est une jolie dit à marc
olivier fogiel le patron de bfm il m'a
dit non je l'utilisais des bêtises pour
moi c'est marc-olivier fogiel qui aurait
dû faire toutes les émissions politiques
rien mais on a besoin d'une star
rectangle et marc olivier fogiel est une
star sur mark o'neill et fogiel c'est un
intervieweur hors pair c'est le meilleur
d'entre nous je vous dis voilà marc
olivier fogiel il est patron de bfm et
je te le dit marco si tu me regardes
maintenant c'est mort mais dans cinq ans
c'est toi qui dois le faire encore dans
mes joues 10 et marc olivier fogiel
aurait dû faire toutes les soirées pour
les présidentielles je vraiment je ne le
pense pas car événement le
patron des faits non là il peut plus non
plus alors on a othman nas rouquette
avec une porte parole de valérie
pécresse il va nous dire toutes les
coulisses de ce de ce moment de télé
mais c'était prévu que ces termes vous
étiez content pas de ce moment c'est un
bon mec à l'arrivée elle a dit ce
qu'elle pensait pouvait calé fait une
bonne télé valérie pécresse hier à
l'émission oui bah tenir trois heures
devant 50 français en répondant sans
fiche pour un parcours toutes leurs
questions c'est pas simple
vous êtes vous êtes heureux c'était un
beau moment de télévision à m mais
surtout je vais vous organisez le rendez
vous ici
je sens que je peux être son délire
je me sens regardez la poigne alors
commencer l'émission j'aurais voulu dire
quelques mots parce que je me suis
clairement posé la question de ma
participation à cette émission ce soir
en raison de l'ouverture d'une enquête
par la justice à la suite d'une plainte
déposée contre monsieur bourdin pour
tentative d'agression sexuelle et
présidente de tous les français je ne
laisserai plus aucune femme avoir peur
de porter plainte la loi du silence
c'est fini
alors ils ont pas pris les meilleurs
moments on va on en voit remettre l'ex
prendre pied dans un instant est ce
qu'elle avait prévu de faire ça à
valérie pécresse bon elle avait dit à la
chaîne oui la veille quand une enquête a
été ouverte nasreen existence juridique
de cette plainte qui a été déposée
contre jean-jacques brot d'art sans
préjuger du fait qu'il soit coupable ou
innocent ça il est présumé innocent elle
a dit m'écouter qu'elle maintenait sa
participation à condition de pouvoir
dire les choses au début de l'émission
alors il y en a sur les réseaux sociaux
qui ont beaucoup aimé et y en a trop dit
que c'était un petit peu dur aux us se
trouve comment on ait trouvé si vous
avez des petites pancartes on vous
demande pas grand-chose en émission si
je vous pouviez le faire
[Rires]
et
moi non plus est ce qu'on a et délation
après les propos de valérie pécresse
vous êtes contre serena
après ces nouveaux projets est ce que
vous trouvez et valérie pécresse a bien
fait de l'apostrophé comme ça changeait
de bordeaux dès le début de l'émission
oui elle ne pouvait pas faire autrement
parce que c'est son combat et elle a
très bien fait je trouve qu'elle l'a
fait sans agressivité c'est ce qu'elle
voulait faire selon mes infos elle elle
n'avait pas écrit mais elle s'est
laissée guider parce qu'alors voulu dire
avec son coeur et je trouve que c'est un
grand moment de télé bravo à elle
c'était parfait moi je couche confirme
que c'était pas effectivement un texte
écrit dont elle ne lisait pas mais c'est
un combat qui lui tient à coeur elle a
parlé avec ses tripes c'est la main mais
rien n 10 ouais qu'est ce qu'on aurait
dit elle aime l'impro rien oui les bains
a relevé m pendant trois heures bah
c'est pour ça que vous devez vraiment
vous rencontrer sir aimez vous organisez
je vois qu'elle aime le rouge et noir
allaient mme jeanne mas
et habillés en rouge noir et blanc lab
la france oui oui je trouve ça fait
plaisir pour une fois de voir quelque
chose qui n'est pas préparé parce que
généralement ce genre de truc là on se
dit bon bah sont dit avant parce que là
on voit vraiment qu'il est étonné de sa
question et que tout on est gêné et que
lui et super g n'est ce qu'il faut pas
que c'est la réponse de bourdin 0
elle a eu raison de le faire parce que
ce soit son combat ou pas ces combats
tout le monde mais et le fait de devoir
le dire au moins à la clau le machin ya
pas de oui mais elle est là bas ça veut
dire qu'on sait pas les têtes dans le
truc non au moins lancé moi je vais vous
dire un truc mais aussi sur l'émission
jean jacques bourdin il est excellent le
matin dans son format avec son micro son
face à face jarrier pas de conseiller
chez de conseil et de la personne en
télé mais je pense que quand on a un
format qui marche il faut rester sur ce
format je pense que si jean jacques
bourdin avait fait il était resté dans
son studio avec son micro il rien
troisième micro pour un intervenant à
chaque fois et il aurait fait face à
face avec mais valérie pécresse dans les
yeux 90 minutes il aurait fait un
million un million de gens suis sûr et
certain je suis persuadé qu'il un format
exceptionnel on attend jean jacques
bourdin là dedans avec ces questions
avec c c'est un terreau pour le voir à
gré et là c'était patron l'a tuée mais
n'ont pas failli devant jean jacques il
est très bon maintenant et on a perdu
changer de boulot mais dallaire que non
mais et il aurait dû fait moi je vous
dis quand on a format ou sinon attention
petit studio on s'en fout ça c'est très
bien mais justement c'est ce que dit
valérie pécresse elle dit moi je suis
pas venu pour jean jacques bourdin je
suis venu pour ces questions des
téléspectateurs c'est qui ce qui ce qui
lie qui les préparent depuis quinze
jours une qu'ils auraient voulu faire
sourire dans le studio parce qu'en fait
il y avait plusieurs concepts dans le
tome aime courir dans une émission c'est
à dire arriver concept on veut aller en
corrèze pour être sur les terres
domaniales et pécresse on veut avoir des
questions de téléspectateurs avaient eu
un truc énorme et si mon émission c'est
elle la jeune fille allait elle était
super franchement aimé c'était une
énorme rigolade c'est à dire que est là
elle était donc public pour présenter
les gens donc avec le mec à côté
alors je suis avec eux jean-françois
kiem le frisbee ababsa si
jean-françois à 43 ans
aime également la vie voilà je sers bien
c'est ça merci et après le bec je suis
un
spécial à cinq mètres de diderot
nécessaire c'était le tube est le
bon chez nous assure celui qui l'aurait
pas marcher sur les gars
c'est excellent mais valérie pécresse
qu'elle a bien su alors moi je les
trouvais absolument incroyable j'ai
trouvé percutant du truc c'était une
master class valérie pécresse je trouve
que par ailleurs le concept n'est
absolument pas abouti et j'ai trouvé
effectivement haubourdin complètement
paumé non plus il faut pas oublier qu'on
est dans le matin oui mais il est bien
il est bien matin mais dans ce concept
là avec les français on avait la maison
c'était un petit enfant qui était
derrière cela vous fait craquer
une deuxième chose il faut pas oublier
qu'on n'entend pas une présidentielle et
que malgré tout cette prise de parole
par rapport aux libérations la parole de
la ram et ça c'est directement contre
zemmour parce que zemmour il a toujours
balayé d'un revers de manche le mythe ou
le ballon sans porc oui un peu genre non
mais en fait y'a pas grand chose c'est
un peu de la fumée ça donc en fait elle
a très bien joué à la fois d'un point de
vue politique et au point de vue
d'acteurs rappelle le score 1 604 mille
téléspectateurs c'est pas nul tout de
suite c'est correct comme score mais
c'est vrai qu'on s'attendait à plus
parce que énormément de communication et
c'était là l'émission politique de jean
jacques bourdin qui était extrêmement
attendu et valérie pécresse donc a pris
la parole tout de suite elle a fait un
monologue de une minute 57
quelques
regards des pandémies 57 et sans
séquelles mais s'adresser à moi qui me
regardent et moi
et regardez la réponse de jean jacques
bourdin je pense que ce n'était pas du
tout prévu je pense qu'il était bon
qu'il n'était pas au courant qu'ils
allaient faire ça la chaîne était au
courant tout cas d'accord hachette est
prêt à donner ces cinq ans où ses
partisans non mais est ce qu il savait
qu'à l'aller on arrêtait tout de suite
lui dire attendez attendez tout de suite
avant de dire bourgenay tout à ce moment
précis mais
alors regardez jean jacques bourdin il
ya un petit peu là il est sonné
franchement il s'est imposé devant vous
avez toutes les arabes et je vais vous
donner la parole car vous êtes quelqu'un
qui a énormément d'infos que c'est un
journaliste émérite hors pair non
vraiment je ne le pense pas mais je m'en
vais du roi
[Rires]
l'émission la france en les yeux
la france dans les yeux avec les
français les françaises et les français
qui sont autour de vous j'imagine clause
est heureuse d'être ici en corrèze
mais avant de commencer l'émission
j'aurais voulu dire quelques mots parce
que je me suis clairement posé la
question de ma participation à cette
émission ce soir en raison de
l'ouverture d'une enquête par la justice
à la suite d'une plainte déposée contre
monsieur bourdin pour tentative
d'agression sexuelle alors je sais qu'il
conteste fermement c'est fait et bien
sûr c'est à la justice de les trancher
et je respecte la présomption
d'innocence à laquelle chacun de nos
compatriotes halte droit mais je
voudrais le dire très clairement je dois
le dire très clairement si ces
accusations sont avérées elles sont
graves et elles doivent être condamnés
vous le savez le combat contre le
harcèlement sexuel et contre les
violences faites aux femmes est un
combat personnel pour moi est trop
longtemps la société a regardé ailleurs
à fermer les yeux a cherché à minimiser
trop de femmes ont eu peur pendant
longtemps de porter plainte et
présidente de tous les français je ne
laisserai plus aucune femme avoir peur
de porter plainte la loi du silence
c'est fini et pour que la parole se
libère et bien il faut que les femmes se
sentent soutenus et avec moi elles le
seront alors voilà je voulais dire les
choses en face parce que je suis franche
et que je suis sans détour si je suis
ici ce soir c'est par respect pour vous
les français qui êtes réunis ce soir
pour me poser les questions que vous
avez préparé depuis une semaine et donc
je suis vraiment là pour vous répondre
je voudrais ajouter les répéteurs
pécresse j'ai décidé de ne pas
m'exprimer à ce sujet mais je conteste
les faits rapportés par la presse et je
laisse la justice faire son travail
il est en rassemblant la la il est
convoqué dans le bureau de
monsieur qui a des infos alors en effet
la chaîne avait peur en fait quelques
jours avant qu'elle annule tout
simplement et c'était un gros dispositif
avec un car régie beaucoup de moyens
donc ça c'est déchirant démission je
sais pas exactement combien ça coûte et
mais effectivement pour bfm c'est
beaucoup plus cher que d'être en studio
avec les zemmour comme ils l'ont fait
voilà maintenant elle avait juste
prévenu effectivement qui aurait qu'elle
voulait deux minutes face calmes
s'adressant aux téléspectateurs mais
elle n'a pas donné le contenu de ce
qu'elle allait dire à la chaîne ça n'a
pas donné penser qu'elle avait parlé
vous non mais non né à jean jacques
bourdin donc personne savait on se
doutait un petit peu de ce qui allait
devenir ne sais pas ce qui va être dit
en revanche jean jacques bourdin et la
chaîne avait prévu la réponse quelle que
soit la phrase il est déjà prévu la
réponse qui serait je n'y vois là je nie
les faits je ne veux pas débattre la
réponse est la bonne elle a répondu
qu'elle était déjà écrite c'est très
exactement pour passer au débat
directement et ne pas rentrer dedans
après selon mes informations
effectivement et personne ne s'attendait
à ce que ce soit aussi dur il a été
assez choqué il a été quand même assez
assez défendu parce que wade y ait pas
beaucoup de gros plan sur lui voilà mais
ça n'a pas trop filmé pendant ce moment
là effectivement il a été il a été très
très surpris et à la fin ils se sont
aimés c'est très dur de vivre un truc
comme ça aux journalistes pression vis
attendais pas je salue à flinguer moins
que l'émission derrière un joli mais
york ya là un moment je crois que tu es
manier l'épée crème vanille matisse elle
a pris la place et je peux vous donner
un avis personnel bien sûr il y avait
grand plaisir voilà la vie personnelle
sont toujours les bienvenues ali au
passage
je suis très surpris vous la défendez
parce que je ne dépends pas lâcher sa
branche manque-t-elle joue un coup de
coeur voilà c'est un moment franchement
je la lis tu qu'on se servir de ça pour
faire effectivement de la politique à ce
moment là mais les agents j'ai trouvé ça
dégueulasse pourquoi parce que pendant
deux ans on parle d'un homme qui encore
une fois il ya une plainte il ya 0 au
havre on en est là et cette femme de
deux choses l'une soit effectivement
elle pensait ce qu'elle disait elle ne
vient pas mais venir donner des leçons
car c'est vraiment une donneuse de
leçons données des sons ça c'est un
homme qui si ça se trouve dans quinze
jours sera totalement blanchi ajoute que
c'est qu'elle est
représentée à l'algérie un homme pendant
deux minutes ces deux minutes
c'est pas mignon ça doit vous laisser
parler tout le temps parler des
politiques qui font de la langue de bois
évitez bris sujet etc on voit là une
quel courage lui dire en face mais de
dire c'est qu'entre être dire quoi mais
de dire que c'est important que la
parole des femmes se libère qu'elle
n'est pas les révéler avoir peur de
porter plainte même face à un animal
s'il est coupable ou pas ça ça les
ravers a été par ailleurs ont
visiblement sa salade ça lui tient à
coeur et il la faut pas pas voir
simplement que la femme politique parce
que si on en croit paris match paris
match raconte que valérie pécresse a été
agressée sexuellement dans une cage
d'escalier elle en a parlé chez laurent
ruquier dans on n'est pas couché en 2010
en face justement de zemmour qui à ce
moment-là ricanait alors c'était voilà
et la séquence a été finalement coupé au
montage et elle elle en a gardé vraiment
beaucoup de meurtrissures et et elle
raconte l état de choc et la capacité à
porter plainte donc là c'est aussi une
façon de boucler la boucle et peut-être
de dire ce qu'elle n'a pas pu dire à ce
moment là donc il ya quelque chose aussi
de leur personnel et c'est peut-être
aussi ça qui fait que ça a été le cas
écrit et la voix du coeur c'était long
franchement et c'est pas de la politique
c'est son combat moi j'ai une de ses
proches babette de rozières que les
conseillères régionales et qui m'a
expliqué que valérie pécresse elle loge
secrètement à paris défunt victime de
violences de tous ordres elle fait ça
parce que c'est son combat et donc elle
ne pouvait pas laisser passer ça mathieu
m6 arrangements c'est sa sincérité qui a
rejailli
je voudrais un autre nom je vais prendre
vous parce que vous êtes à deux non mais
moi moi j'ai trouvé ça inappropriée et
humiliant mais trc seconde à la place de
jean jacques bourdin vous traversez une
période difficile ushuaia là bas mais je
les essaie de ne pas communiquer et là
dans votre propre émission vous est pris
en otage pendant deux minutes par wendel
avait prévenu il aurait pu le placer
pendant l'émission à la fin d'émission
cela l'a complètement déstabilisée il
est humilié pendant la diffusion
sur le fond pas la première à venir sur
le plateau de quelqu'un ça veut dire
qu'on cautionne tout ce qui est d'accord
toutes les accusations et c'était
d'ailleurs un il aurait dû le pour le
protéger lui le retirer parce que
évidemment que ça allait se passer comme
ça évidemment il se fait atomiser en 30
secondes qu'il la voit il a la voix
tremblante mais non mais c'est
impossible que des gens professionnels
n'est pas imaginer une seconde qu'il ait
laissé passer ça c'est pas vrai et elle
est obligée de le faire aller même si
encore une fois on sait pas qui est
coupé g et al est obligé de me faire
c'est une faute ils ont pas ils ont dû
le protéger lui même au delà ce risque
c'est la chaîne qui d'ici là oui ma
dérive jusqu'ici l'émission avec jean
jacques bourdin je dirais c'est à dire
sur ce sujet là et heureusement qu'elle
l'a fait parce que c'est un combat qui
lui très cher peut-être pas
d'aujourd'hui elle l'a fait la doubler
le nombre de logements disponibles à la
région pour les femmes victimes de
violence on a mis en place deux
téléphones grave danger quand une femme
est attaqué par son conjoint enfin il ya
tout l'alertent l' alerte à la demande
pour les bus la nuit pour les femmes qui
ont peur de rentrer chez elles que c'est
un convaincu lui très cher et donc
forcément elle ne peut pas ne rien dire
a poussé la choisir le dessus les
associés maryse imaginons oui et
imaginons que la sphère dégénère après
elle ne pouvait pas ne pas le dire oui
en fait elle n'avait pas écrit parce que
elle voulait vraiment vivre le moment et
c'est vrai qu'elle avait prévenu le la
chaîne mais elle ne voulait surtout pas
que jean jacques bourdin sache ce
qu'elles allaient dire la vega redescend
secret il n'y avait que quelques proches
qui connaissait parce qu'elle avait un
peu répété avec eux ce qu'elle allait
dire mais aucune fiche est pas
d'avertissement jean jacques bourdin
elle visait en face face à face jean
jacques bourdin il voulait s'adresser à
lui